- What's up believe nation?
It's Evan.
My one word is believe.
And I believe in people
more than they believe
in themselves and my sincere
hope is that if you see
in you, what I see in you, you'll be able
to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey today,
I'm going to talk about
the seven ways to discover
your strengths and weaknesses.
- [Introductory Music] Nine, eight, go.
- So the question I get
asked a lot by different
entrepreneurs trying to
figure out their path,
figure out where they're going to go is,
"What am I good at? What am I
strong at? What am I weak at?
"And how do I use that to
build a successful business?"
So today I'm going to share
with you my seven tips
on how to discover your
strengths and weaknesses.
Tip number one is just
think about what do you
have the most fun doing?
A lot of times we get too in our head,
we're too analytical,
we're too data-oriented,
we're too process-oriented and
an easy way to step out of it
is to just think, "What do I enjoy doing?
"What do I have the most fun doing?
"What do I get lost in?"
We all have something
that we can get lost in.
And now it is there's no stupid answers
'cause you could turn almost
anything into a career.
You know, 10 years ago, if
you said that you wanted
to be a gamer, that
wouldn't have worked out.
You wouldn't have been able to make money
as a professional gamer but now,
a lot of professional
gamers are making more than
our parents made right?
If you're a faker, or if
you're a double lift or
if you're in the legal legend
scene or the other games
as well, like you're making some money.
And that is doable.
Another option.
If you like hanging out with your friends.
If you're really people-oriented person,
that's a strong strength.
That my lead you to a
career in HR or a business
as a speaker or a business
as a coach or consultant
with other people.
So just think about before
trying to figure out
how it's all going to make sense,
that's what we always get caught up.
Before thinking about how does
this turn into a perfect plan
for myself, just think about
what can I get lost in?
What do I love doing?
If I didn't have
responsibilities, or the great
question, if I had all
the money in the world,
what would I do with my time?
Yes, you're going to travel.
Yes, you're going to buy whatever.
You're going to buy all this stuff.
Great.
You still have money left over.
You still have time in abundance.
What are you going to do?
'Cause you'll get sick of traveling.
You'll get sick of buying stuff.
You'll need to do something
that has a little bit more
meaning to your life.
I promise you, you'd be
saying, "No that's not true".
It's true. It'll happen.
So what would you do if
you had that kind of money?
What would you do with your time?
And thinking about that,
then allows you to think,
"Then okay, I really like those things".
From there, you can
pull out your strengths
and weaknesses.
Really making lists of the
things that you can get
lost in and that you just love doing.
Step number two is think
about what you daydream about.
So, it may not be what
you're doing right now,
but when you lie in bed
about to pass out or when you
are in the shower thinking
or when you're walking
through nature going on
a hike, or when you're
traveling or lying on the
beach or whatever it is
that you kind of get hit
with some inspiration,
what do you daydream about doing?
Maybe, you're not doing
it yet, but you wish
you could do it.
You have these crazy dreams
sometimes that I wish
I could be doing that or
people you look up to.
When you think about
what you daydream about,
again don't make it practical yet.
Just write down a list of
things that you wish you
could be spending your time on.
You wish you could be doing.
And then, I would try
to find some small way
to actually start doing it.
The test to see if you like it,
To see if you're good at it.
A lot of times, the grass is
greener on the other side.
A lot of times, that
thing that you want to do,
once you start doing it, is
way too much work and not
what you thought it was going to be.
And you don't want to do it anymore.
But sometimes, when you do
it, it's like, "I love this.
"I want to keep doing it".
So, you never know, until you get started.
I never thought I'd be a salsa dancer.
I never thought I would
run a salsa school,
invest and buy it.
I'd never thought that'd
be part of my plan.
I'm tall, I didn't speak Spanish.
You know, I take big steps.
I didn't learn the music growing up.
It's all on paper, there's
all the reasons why
it would never work out
for me as a salsa dancer
but I just loved it and I went to a class.
I wanted to go back.
I wanted to do it again.
Same thing as YouTube videos.
My first videos sucked.
They really were bad.
But I liked it.
I liked the process.
I wanted to do it again.
And I wanted to do it again.
I wasn't getting any results.
I wasn't getting any
comments, no views, no shares,
nothing.
I just loved it so I had to do
it again and again and again.
And so, instead of making
it some big plan on what
you want to do with your life;
that can seem overwhelming.
That can seem depressing.
It's upsetting because
you don't have clarity.
I would just think about the things
that you have some daydreams about.
That you wish you could do and then find,
some small way to get started.
Just hit that little bit of the pyramid
instead of just thinking
about it as this huge project,
just this little thin wedge,
this little tiny piece to test it.
To say "yes" to one thing.
You could say "yes" to
going to try rock climbing
without having to become a
professional rock climber.
You could say "yes" to going out on a date
with one girl to see how it works out,
without having to get married to her.
Right?
So say "yes". Try it.
The thing you have in your
mind, find some small way
to get started.
And then you'll see if you enjoy it
and if your strengths come out.
Tip number three is think
about what do you do
differently than others?
You are a strange duck in some respects.
You are not exactly like everybody else.
You're not the same as
all your other friends.
You are your own unique little snowflake.
And so, what is it that you
do or the way that you think
that is just different than other people?
It's an important question to ask because
a lot of times you may not
see those things as strengths,
you may even see those
things as weaknesses.
That because you're
different, you're not good
like the other people
are at this other thing.
But you see the world slightly differently
than other people do.
And where do you stand
out compared to the people
around you?
And just asking that
question, will pull out
some things that are very interesting.
So, for me, I'm very mission-driven.
I'm also very pragmatic.
I don't really hang out a lot
of times just going for beer,
and watching movies with friends.
A lot of times, there's a
purpose behind what I do.
There's a purpose behind
the conversations I have.
I don't like dealing with small problems.
I want to look behind it
to see the bigger cause
and go out and solve that big thing.
That could be a weakness
in some social settings
but it's also a strength
for me in that it allows me
to build this business.
It allows me to build this movement.
It allows me to create great content
and videos for you guys.
And so just asking yourself,
what do I do that's different
than most people?
Again, without thinking
about how it's going to apply
practically down the road,
just what do I do that's different?
Or what do I think
about in a different way
than the people around me?
And make a list and though
there you'll be able to find
some of the what you might
have thought were weaknesses
but could actually be strengths
for your future career.
- So tip number four is be
brutally honest with yourself.
All of us are so unique and
we have different strengths
and weaknesses.
And sometimes, admitting to
some of them could be really
embarrassing for us.
So for example, I'm an
organizational disaster.
I don't do well with organization at all.
Which is why I have to create
structure around my life.
I have to schedule my
days to do specific things
because if I don't, I'm
going to fall off track
and I'll just find
myself lying on the floor
staring at the ceilings, dreaming about
a brighter future.
The truth is that brighter
future will never come
if I don't do something
about my organization.
That's why I stick to my
schedule as much as possible
and I only stray away from
it when there's something
urgent that needs to be taken care of.
And on the other side,
I did not want to admit
that my strength is empathy.
Especially when I started
out in the workforce
and I was up against all these alpha-males
and they're like, "Oh,
you're such as woman.
"You just want to hold hands
and hug people and feel
"where people are feeling".
And I hid it inside of me for a long time.
And I took on personas
that wasn't even mine.
And then eventually, I admitted to myself.
Empathy is not only a strength
for me, it's my super power.
It allows me to feel what
other people are feeling.
My mission is to help people.
What better way to help people
than feel what they're feeling
and really understand what
they're going through?
I think most of us are
aware of our strengths
and weaknesses.
The only thing you need
to do is just be brutally
honest with yourself.
- Number five is use your
friends as counselors
but not jailers.
So one of the things we tend
to do when we don't know
the answer to something,
is we ask our friends.
And our friends can be a great window
into understanding us a little bit better.
Asking your friend what
you think your strengths
and weaknesses are can
give you a perspective
on yourself.
The thing is though, you
have to be careful about it.
Because your friends see one side of you.
They see a certain side
that maybe one friend
sees one side, another
friend sees another side,
and there's still a piece
of you too that's hidden,
that you haven't shared with anybody,
that you just keep to yourself,
that you don't want exposed.
And so, the positive
of asking your friends
what you think you're
strengths and weaknesses are
is that you get some insight into you
and to that side that you are showing.
The negative side though
is that because they only
see one aspect of you, that
that becomes your jail cell.
That because this is how they see you,
you have to continue
behaving only in that way
and going on those strengths
and you're missing this
whole other part that you're not sharing.
And so, I'm always
reluctant on any of these
personal development
exercises and self-awareness,
because that is what it is.
It's your self-awareness.
I'm always reluctant to go outside
and ask other people.
I think your time is
better spent with yourself.
Spend more time with yourself
than time with other people
if you want to understand yourself
because the answers are
here, not out there.
But if you want to, it
gives you a perspective.
So again, use your friends as counselors
but not as jailers.
You don't have to live
up to their expectations
or that one side of you
and spending some good time with yourself
to reflect, to write down,
to spend time in nature,
to think about the whole you and
what you're really good at
and where you want to focus
is important.
Tip number six is ask yourself
what do you hate doing?
Often the way to find what you're good at,
is by thinking about
what you're not good at.
So just like in the
process of your one word,
some people find it easier
to find their one word,
their one most important core value,
by going positive,
thinking about all the good
things in their life
and figuring out what their most important
core value is.
Some people can't get down
to it only going positive.
They find it better going
opposite, going negative.
So think about the people
who you can't stand
being around.
What values do they have?
What's just like toxic to you?
You can't stand being around
these kinds of people.
Or being in these kinds of situations.
And by figuring out that,
that's your anti-word,
you can figure out your one word.
And so think about what you hate doing.
Think about what other
people may like doing,
the people around you, they enjoy doing
but for you it's like, "I can't believe
"people like doing that".
What would you absolutely
hate spending your time on
every single day?
And that gets you to a list of weaknesses
and the opposite will be
what you're really good at.
So what is the thing that
you absolutely hate doing
and then what's the
exact opposite of that?
Chances are, that's where
you should be playing.
And tip number seven
is just say "Yes" more.
If you have no idea what your passion is,
If you have no idea what your strengths
and your weaknesses are,
just say "yes" more.
When someboody invites
you to do something,
don't immediately judge it and say,
"Well this is not going to be for me".
Say "yes". Try it. See
if you want to go back.
See if you want to do it again.
See if it sparked anything.
We talked about not putting
up so much pressure on it
being the perfect thing
and making it some big,
huge project and it has to
work out.
But also just exposing
yourself to more things,
exposing yourself to opportunities
that maybe your parents
wouldn't agree with
or maybe it wasn't a part of your culture,
but it's still kind of curious for you.
If something hits on your radar and say,
"Hmm, that's interesting"
or a friend comes
and tells you, "I want you
to come out to this thing",
at least try it once.
It's good to adopt the mentality of to try
almost anything.
You know within reason.
Once.
Try new foods once.
Try a new club once.
Try a new activity once.
Try a new kind of movie once.
If you've tried it and it
doesn't work out, great.
You know, you don't have to do it again.
But at least, trying it once.
Because I think most of the
time we discount so many things
that we've never even tried.
We're judging things
we've never even spent
any amount of time on
and then you just constantly
live in this narrow lane.
And that's probably not
even the best path for you.
There's some path way out
here that you don't even
know you should be on
because you never bothered
expanding your horizon.
So if you feel lost, if you
feel like you don't know
what you're strengths
and your weaknesses are,
if you like you don't know
what you're passionate about,
then try multiple things
at least once say "yes"
to a lot of things and if
it doesn't work, great.
Kill it.
You don't have to make
a lifelong commitment
to being a salsa dancer.
If you go to a class, you don't like it,
but at least say "yes" once.
Try it.
See if it's for you.
See if you want to go back.
Expand that reach, say "yes"
once to almost anything
and through that process,
you'll discover your passion,
your strengths and your weaknesses.
So those are my seven
tips on how to discover
your strengths and weaknesses.
I'd love to know what do you guys think?
What was your favorite tip?
What's most relevant to you?
Resonated the most?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Did I miss an eight, nine,
ten that you want to add
to the list?
Leave in the comments.
I'm really curious to find out.
And also if you're
commenting within the first
couple of hours of this video going live,
then you have a chance
to win one of our two
daily prizes.
Now I made this vide because
Kami Ragan asked me to.
So if there's a topic you
would like me to cover
in a future seven ways
video, check out the link
in the description.
You can go cast your vote,
you can vote on other
people's topics or come up with your own.
And maybe you'll get lucky
and we'll profile it soon.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Hugo Beyer.
Hugo, thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book "Your One Word"
and taking that picture
and sending it to me.
I'm curious what you're looking at.
Something on the ceiling.
Something happening up there.
I want to know next
time but thank you again
for posting.
I really appreciate the
support and I hope you enjoyed
the book.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.